largos minutos de golpes e insultos
racistas
esta escena de violencia policial podría
haber permanecido oculta hecha pública
el jueves por los aires muestra la
paliza de un hombre por tres policías en
su informe lo acusan de tratar de robar
sus armas sin aportar pruebas
tengo miedo la gente que tiene que
protegerme me está robando he tenido
suerte a diferencia de otros de tener
vídeos que me protegen si no no estaría
aquí hoy el ministro de interior ya
saldrá maná ha solicitado el despido de
los policías involucrados y una
investigación interna los que dijo que
cuando la gente mete la pata debe dejar
el uniforme de la república debe dejar
este trabajo debe ser castigada por la
justicia del país tres días antes fueron
estas imágenes las que impactaron
refugiados evacuados a la fuerza de la
plaza de la republica algunos fueron
maltratados por los agentes de policía
más tarde acusados de uso
desproporcionado de la fuerza hechos que
despiertan controversia en torno a la
ley de seguridad global y su artículo 24
que penaliza la difusión mal
intencionada de imágenes de las fuerzas
del orden ante la oleada de rechazo el
primer ministro son castex propuso el
jueves una reescritura del artículo en
el que muchos ven un ataque a la
libertad de informar